good morning despite the dire warnings
and the job cuts there is a glimmer of
hope for air travel today Europe's
biggest airline Ryanair says it will
restore 40 percent of its flights by 1st
of July it says that both crew and
passengers will need to wear face masks
and past temperature check that news
comes as the industry warns of awful
consequences from government plans to
bring in a 14-day quarantine period for
arriving passengers I spoke to Michael
O'Leary the chief executive a rider a
little earlier we 40% of the program
that's about a thousand flights a day up
from about 30 flights a day at the
moment and but we think those flights
were probably between 50 to 60% but
lower than our our normal low effective
but it's important we get the business
back moving again and offer people a
holiday before the schools restart in
September and what about the middle
seats will you be selling those we'd be
selling those I mean they're a vital
part particularly families traveling
need to sit together people with young
children need to sit together I think
you know we've released it two and a
half minute video this morning on
improved health measures we are
requiring people and also our pastors
and our our own people to wear face
masks we will have some element of
distancing you won't be allowed to queue
for the toilets things like that the
content the payments are going to be
contactless so we'll be doing our level
best to minimize physical contact while
still allowing people to avail of great
low fares to travel to and from the
continent of Europe and you're reopening
in most of your 80 European bases any
notable exceptions no not at this point
in time you know what we're trying to do
we won't have very high frequencies
unlike the major trunk routes to Dublin
it Aereo the Dublin London is London
Italy London Spain what we're trying to
do is to get almost every route
restarted but with a reduced frequency
and so there's really no exceptions the
one possibility is that loud emotion
it's based in Vienna may well be closed
if they don't reach agreement with the
unions they're on the 20th of May at the
end of this month
which countries do you get the sense on
the ground or returning most closely to
normality currently at the moment Dean
that would be more Central and Eastern
Europe Germany
as returning to know Austria's returning
to normality you know I think gradually
and remember we're only starting talking
about flying on the 1st of July which is
still six weeks away we think most of
Europe would have returned to some
degree of normality now normality would
still be flying with masks temperature
checks and sanitizers but at least we'll
allow people to return to flying reunite
friends and families get people back to
work and we start the tourism ministry
not just in Europe but also here in the
UK as well under all the airports in the
state of preparedness they're
increasingly yes we're working with all
of them and the airport's will be
operating temperature checks people who
haven't had temperature of over 38
degrees will be asked to return home and
self isolate and I think it's that
combination of temperature checks and
masks that we give us a high degree of
confidence as they already have proven
successful in Asia the people can fly
freely without passing on the covert 19
foreign governments to do though is not
to have ineffective measures things like
the two-week isolation in the UK which
has no science base to it at all
particularly when you decide at midnight
you're going to exempt the French and
there's no argument for allowing people
to travel to the UK if you come from
countries outside France you to isolate
for two weeks but if you come from
France somehow you're frying despite the
fact that the French is what has one of
the EU countries with the highest rate
of covert 19 incidences
yes it's 14 day quarantine period in the
UK presumably you're anticipating that's
going to hit demand to and from the UK
for me I don't and I think you know
what's regrettable about it is it's
unenforceable and it's unbelievable you
know it's one of these measures that I
think people will largely ignore which
is not good and you know I think what
the UK government should have done was
to start with effective measures and
that is faced and temperature controls
on arriving passengers not ineffective
measures like two-week lock downs which
most people will ignore any way so you
don't anticipate demand from UK
passengers being noticeably weaker in
this relaunch we don't think so I mean I
think what we're really anticipating
here is lots of UK families will want to
go to Spain to Portugal to Italy for a
two-week break they'll be coming back to
the UK well
- well before two weeks before the
schools return in September I think they
will be able to observe the locked our
two-week isolation period despite the
fact that a two-week isolation period is
going to be completely ineffective
anyway and is not science-based because
you're exempting the French and this
this reopening plan that you've
announced today is that gonna have any
bearing on the job losses that you've
announced recently no I mean
unfortunately you know we've flown
effectively nobody during the months of
April May and June we would hope to
carry about 50% of our planned
passengers through July August September
that still means we're operating at
about 25% of towing capacity through the
peak six months of our our year we've
started negotiations with our unions in
the UK the pilots and chemical unions
regrettably we're going to lose about
3,000 jobs that's the minimum figure
that's the figure that's been will be
the jobs losses if we agree a 20% pay
cut
we're also relating this week announcing
head off as job losses here in Dublin in
Poland and in Spain where we have large
office engine as well these are deeply
regretable but we have to face facts
this is a year when Ryanair only carry
less than 100 million passengers
compared to a normal year where we carry
150 million passengers sadly we just
don't have enough jobs